I'm kind of in an iphone rut that I
Sorenson like five years now and I'm a
bit afraid to switch over anywhere else
just because I don't know if an Android
or any other operating system will have
nearly as many acts or the same map well
Dan let's break this down if you're
deciding between an iphone and an
android phone the Russian of apps isn't
really a question both platforms have
over 800,000 apps and access to most of
the major services the question between
Android and iPhone comes when you're
looking at premium apps like kids games
or even just regular games those tend to
come to the iphone first because there
are more paying customers in the apple
itunes store but the real Paul should
come if you're considering a windows
phone or a blackberry both of those
platforms are far behind Apple and
Google especially when it comes to those
premium content apps also if there's a
new app it's probably going to come to
Windows Phone or blackberry last
Instagram just came to Windows Phone
hope that helps will be here next week
answering really important tech
questions like this one yes and yes and
tweet us your tech questions with the
hashtag ask wsj d